giving you the same financial advice
your grandmother would only I keep my
teeth in this is the Dave Ramsey show
thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you're here here in the lobby of
the headquarters of Ramsey solutions
Brooks and Vicki are with us hey guys
how are you hey welcome it's good to
have you guys where are you from
Raleigh North Carolina awesome very cool
and here all the way to Nashville is
your debt-free screen that's right this
is a climbing the mountain so I love it
so how much have you paid off eighty
nine thousand six hundred and sixty one
dollars in eighteen months way to go way
to go making what kind of money two
hundred and twenty thousand to two fifty
whoa okay I give up what do you guys do
for a living
nothing so that works yeah no we we
actually work in real estate Quality
Assurance quality assurance and real
estate okay not a bad gig it's working
for you we're excited we feel blessed
now very cool good for you
congratulations
it's an incredible income and an
incredible story so what kind of debt
was this the bad debt so it was a
mixture of cars and unfortunately credit
cards cars and credit cards are many
thousand bucks oh yeah no student loans
in there no student loans in there so
Vicky told me the story what happened
eighteen months ago because you guys are
be popping along making a ton of money
got a big pile of debt and all of a
sudden something happened what was it he
started listening to your show oh there
it is right there and then he comes home
with all these crazy bad ideas for this
crazy gallon radio what did you say oh I
was all-in oh okay
you were just happy he finally found
somebody it could be his idea so Brooks
what happened in your head because she's
been trying to get you to do it all
these years to get the debt paid off and
and you're riding along listen to us on
the car what what what caused the switch
to flip you know sometimes you come to a
point in your life and you wreck
as your own stupidity I had lived years
on a debt fueled lifestyle i I was a
master of making perpetually bad choices
when it came to finances and I shifted
the burden of my reckless spending onto
my wife by dis distancing myself from
the finances so I didn't want to have
conversations with her I just figured if
I made enough money she'll figure out
how to pay the bills and I came to the
realization that that's not how some
somebody should love their spouse and I
love my wife
but you're not showing love when you
take finances that eat a marriage from
within and you behave recklessly and
I've become to realize I listen to your
show and one of the beauty that I that I
got from listening was that debt doesn't
have to be normal and you're one of the
few people that standing crying out in
the wilderness telling people you don't
have to take on debt debt is not okay
and I came to think that well car loans
will be a part of my life I'll just
always have a car loan everybody has a
car loan and and you're saying no you
don't have to have a car loan live smart
live responsibly and you don't have to
pay tens of thousands in interest to
somebody else for the privilege of
driving something that becomes worthless
same as credit cards and those things
buried they stole from my family the
flexibility to be able to bless my
family and so when making all this money
in disappearing yeah Vicki Vicki how
long have y'all been married 26 years 26
years and this guy I mean that was a
great that was a great sermon right
there I mean I was wives everywhere
going yeah yeah it was very well done I
mean is he really doing this
absolutely that's pretty cool so you've
been carrying all the weight all along
and he's just tried out on his stupidity
which is what I tried to do Brooks oh I
can relate he was just trying to make
enough to make it all okay but you you
were you were the only one carrying the
water and he comes in and says I'm gonna
help what did that do to your heart oh I
cried I've been praying for that for you
and so when it happened it was it was
just a miracle yeah Wow let me tell you
I'm man cried and and I I I wrote in the
letter I said we want to come on to
celebrate this this is a moment of joy
and embarrassment at the same time
because it's terrible to create a
problem only to solve it so for those
who haven't experienced debt and bad
behaviors credit cards don't create the
problem to solve it so you know we we
kind of looked at this and said you know
I needed to be a loving husband and he'd
be responsible I need to stop behaving
like a kid so at the end of the day we
we made the commitment I said I'm gonna
change so Vicky wasn't ever a part of
this because you you know you wanted the
help but then when he gets in there and
starts actually putting his hands on
your systems and stuff was there ever a
part you're like wait a minute
absolutely yeah be careful what you wish
for huh yeah so what was the biggest
budget fight you guys had in the last 18
months well I would say we went in to
buy a water softener cartridge and I
said we don't we don't have money
allocated enough in the budget to buy
the cartridge and she looked at me like
I was a lunatic so but you know she has
been a loving supportive caring and
patient with me mm-hmm
and she she smiled we ended up getting a
filter cuz I took it from my allowance
but as you should I love it that's just
great you guys that's incredible all
right when people hear you paid off
ninety thousand bucks in 18 months and
they say how did you do that what do you
tell them the secrets the key principles
to getting out of debt are you know for
us it was recognizing that there's a
problem it's terrible to be lost and not
know it
needing to be motivated to solve the
problem
specific goals and realize that the
year-end we broke down the debt and said
look to pay off this debt to pay forty
nine hundred dollars a month I need to
pay eleven hundred twenty-one dollars a
week and need to pay a hundred and sixty
dollars a day need to pay six sixty
seven an hour eleven cents a minute
that's what needs to be done to retire
this debt in the timeframe that we want
to do it and so then by backing into
that said well now this is the rest
we've got to live on so but at the end
of the day when we made that that last
payment vehicles paid off credit cards
paid off and you know told said a man
cried you know I I'm a former Marine
infantryman not simply things that I
like to do is cry but the relief of
knowing one that we'd accomplished what
we set out to and we were going to be
good stewards with what God has blessed
us with but for me the the the remorse
the deep remorse that for 20-plus years
I had burdened my life and so Vicki what
were the key principles for you that
caused you in the last eighteen months
to be able to turn this around as far as
you're concerned if you other people are
listening and then you were gonna advise
them so you need do this this and this
to get out of debt well you have to
stick with your plan but for me it was
letting my husband take control of that
the finances and lead us and you you had
a say though right oh absolutely but I
been doing it by myself for so long that
you know maybe I had a different idea of
which bills should be paid first and
then he came in and messed it all up you
know but um okay so so learning to work
together was one of them really yeah any
other principles no not to come to mind
okay great you guys are incredible I'm
so proud of you
way to go very very well done all right
it's Brooks and Vicki from Raleigh North
Carolina ninety thousand dollars paid
off in eighteen months making 222 250
completely revolutionized a 26 year
marriage in the process count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
ready baby
ten nine eight we're debt-free
love it congratulations you two very
very well done
you